so we've got some pretty weak
information here
you you heard that that medical expert
on msnbc at the top say
look we don't know if you take the
vaccine does that mean that you
can no longer be infected or you just
won't show symptoms or it won't be that
serious or you
we just don't know well yeah it sounds
like you don't know a lot of things
sounds like you don't know what what the
vaccine does sounds like you don't know
what the side effects are going to be
sounds like you don't know what the
primary effect is going to be sounds
like you don't
really know how many people have died
from the virus as separate from dying
with the virus
sounds like you don't know anything at
all experts
actually it sounds like the people who
are inexpert and just have a modicum of
common sense
know much more about this than anybody
else the people who say we're going to
live our lives
well for some reason we're still
deferring to these geniuses and lab
coats
and those geniuses and lab coats are
canceling christmas
dr fauci who remains in that job
now for almost a half century seriously
this guy's worked in public health at a
serious
senior level for almost 50 years
dr fauci is saying no christmas the
guy's gotten
basically everything wrong during this
coronavirus epidemic
but he's saying you have it's just
science you have to cancel christmas
quote from dr fauci said this to the
washington post
i'm going to be with my wife period
the christmas holiday is a special
holiday for us because christmas eve is
my birthday
all done hold on
not christmas is a special holiday for
us because it's the birth of our savior
not uh christmas is important for us
because
uh it's the incarnation of the second
person of the blessed trinity
who redeems mankind no which is usually
why people say no it's because it's my
birthday because everything's
about dr fauci it's a special holiday
because it's my birthday oh okay and
then he goes and christmas day is
christmas day
and my daughters are not going to come
home that's painful we all like that
that's just one of the things you're
going to have to accept as we get
through this
unprecedented challenging time nothing
about this virus is unprecedented it's a
new strain of some kind of virus but new
strains of viruses pop up with some
frequency
what makes this unprecedented is the
stupid
incoherent inhuman unconstitute
anti-constitutional
political response to the virus that's
what makes it unprecedented and you know
what
we can fix that in two seconds you know
how you fix that ignore dr fauci
moreover defy dr fauci which i'm
certainly going to do
i'm going to gather with friends and
family and loved ones on christmas
i encourage you to do that as well be
prudent if you have some particular
reason why you're not going to do that
might not even involve health it might
just be that you don't like your
mother-in-law
okay i understand that but as a general
rule
celebrate christmas people don't listen
to this
ridiculous person in a lab coat this
technocrat
who thinks that he can run your life now
he should not be able to run your life
by the way he's not the only one i beat
up on dr fauci because he absolutely
deserves it
and because he's the most prominent
public health technocratic tyrant in
this country
but there are people doing this all over
the world they're doing this
in britain too there are calls all over
the place not just don't celebrate
christmas
actually maybe you just postpone
christmas the uh advisors
the officials the scientists in britain
say just have a summer party seriously
celebrate christmas in the summer
i i have friends who have done christmas
in july as a sort of silly
party that's not a substitute for
christmas christmas happens at a real
time and
i think this is one of the sort of
temptations
of liberal modernity is we think that
time doesn't matter
oh you lose a year because fouchy told
you to stay indoors okay that's fine
we're going to live forever it doesn't
matter you don't need to do things in
real time you don't need to do things in
real flesh and blood
you can do it on zoom do it on skype
facetime do it in july who cares it's
all the same it's this
this rationalizing abstracting idea
that is completely antithetical to the
christmas season right the whole the
whole point of christmas
is that this metaphysical being the
source of all creation
the second person of the trinity becomes
incarnate in a particular body in a
particular cave
in a particular place bethlehem at a
particular time
coincidentally zero a.d
what what were the odds of that all
right we're probably pretty good
in a particular moment in time
that particularity is key
[Music]
[Music]